Alright,
so I want to go through a lot of
material today and hopefully I've
hopefully that'll work out.
It should,
so so far what we've been doing is
laying out an argument that you inhabit
what you might describe as a frame of
reference or a story or that you're
occupied by sequential subpersonalities.
That's another reasonable way of
thinking about it might be the most
reasonable way of thinking about it
really,
and that these frames of reference or
subpersonalities have a point of view
and to source associated thoughts and
associated memories and that most
importantly perhaps as well as directing
your behavior and emotions.
They also structure your perceptions and
I think that's the most critical.
That's the most critically important
realization about the frames that you
bring to bear on the world because they.
It's through them that the world
manifests itself and what that means to
some degree is that you,
you,
you have an indeterminant role to play
as a consequence of your moral choices.
Because these are essentially value
based structures.
As a consequence of your moral choices.
You determined to do an indeterminant
degree.
The manner in which the world manifests
itself to you,
so in that sense you're a cocreator of
your own being and then you're also a
cocreator through your action and your
communication for the being of other
people as well and and,
and,
and for the external world in so far as
you act upon it.
So it's a nontrivial realization too to
understand that to what degree your
value structures filter the world for
you and shape it.
And so we've been talking so far about
the structure of that world and I,
I introduced some neurophysiological
ideas last time.
They got the idea being that you come
into the world obviously embodied with,
with a set of inbuilt,
we'll call them subpersonalities at
hand.
Most of them,
those are regulated by very archaic,
ancient brain systems that you share
with many other creatures on the
evolutionary chain,
which is partly why you can communicate
with and understand other creatures.
Because if you didn't share that
underlying biological structure,
they would be opaque to you.
In the same way that perhaps an octopus
is relatively opaque to you.
You know you,
you can't understand it because you
don't share an embodied platform and its
experiences,
therefore entirely foreign to you,
but you share your embodied platform,
certainly very specifically with all
mammals and of course you understand
mammals quite well,
but you can even really understand
blizzards to some degree and especially
the more social ones and so there's this
tremendous degree of inbuilt biological
structure and biological commonality and
we talked about it most particularly in
reference to the Hypothalamus,
which seems to be the the,
the built in initial subpersonality
generator or something like that and the
hypothalamus is responsible for
regulating what you might regard as the
most fundamental biological elements of
behavior.
The things that the systems that not
only keep you alive,
which is obviously very important,
but also impel you to do such things as
defend yourself.
Obviously part of survival and also to
reproduce and to explore and the
exploration elements quite interesting
because you think of that as a very
sophisticated form of behavior and it
is,
but it's rooted in an unbelievably
archaic neurophysiology.
So the hypothalamus roughly sets you
into motivated frames and then when
those frames either fail or when they're
all acquiescent because they'd been
satiated,
it pops you into an exploratory state of
mind and you wander around exploring
foraging for information,
roughly speaking,
so that you can update all the
subpersonalities that you use to to
organize your perceptions and frame your
emotions and so forth.
Now the so the hypothalamus throws up
these frames that makes you hungry,
it makes you thirsty,
it makes you defensively aggressive.
It helps regulate your temperature
through behavior and all of those
things.
Now the problem with that is that it's a
set of impulsive unit dimensional
systems.
Each one operating in the moment and
each one only concerned with the
satiation of its particular aim will
say.
And the problem with that is that while
you live for more than the moment you
live across many moments,
you stretch yourself across time.
And we know human beings know that they
stretch across time and so actually have
to consider not only the organization of
their behavior in the short term,
but also the organization of their
behavior.
In the short term so that it also works
across weeks and across months and
across years and maybe even for longer
spans of time than that and also equally
and similarly it has to work across
people and one of the things that's kind
of interesting about that is there
actually isn't much difference between
establishing a value structure that
works for you now and next week and next
month and into the future and
establishing a value structure that
works for you and other people
simultaneously because you could say
that whoever you are in a year is sort
of like another person and so in so far
as you can organize yourself so that
other people find what you're doing,
let's say acceptable and valuable.
You're also organizing yourself so that
perhaps you're acting in the best
interests of your future self and so
then you might say,
well,
if the hypothalamus can,
can,
can organize your,
your,
your being such that you can satiate
satisfy your most basic needs.
Why do you need the rest of the brain?
And answer to that is,
well,
it looks like it's to solve the problem
of more complex forms of being so these,
these fundamental biological subsystems
have to interact with each other in a
productive way.
They can't just cycle unit dimensionally
from motivated state to motivated state.
It's not a very effective solution and
not only that,
you have to learn to operate in a world
with time and with other people and so
that makes the,
the,
the adaptation problem much,
much more complex.
And it's for that reason as far as I can
tell enough,
no doubt for other reasons as well that
there's,
there is utility in the provision of
extra subcortical and cortical
resources.
And I think the right way to think about
the cortex in some ways is actually as
living space for the hypothalamus and
the subcortical structures.
So you know what happens when you're,
when you develop as a young child,
especially in the very early stages of
development,
the underlying subcortical systems,
including the systems for the census,
more or less compete for Don Dominion
over the cortical territory.
So for example,
if you take a kitten and you closed one
of its eyes shortly after birth and you
leave it covered for a number of months,
what will happen is the,
the remaining I will invade both
hemispheres,
visual representation systems so that it
becomes this angle remaining eye becomes
much more acute and more critically
dominant,
like an invader,
really like an invader.
Then the other one does.
And then if you uncover the other eye,
the cat after a critical period of
development that cat will never learn to
see out of that eye.
And so,
you know,
you've got these underlying biological
systems,
motivational and sensory,
and they're looking to expand themselves
as the organism manifests itself in the
world.
And it does that by occupying cortical
territory in a competitive process.
So for example,
if you're deaf,
your,
uh,
your visual cortex will become occupied
by auditory and tactile process because
why not?
You know what I mean?
You can basically see with your hands,
you know,
and you can,
you can.
Well,
I wouldn't say it's not so easy to hear
with your eyes.
That's harder,
although you can hear to some degree
with touch,
right,
because you can feel vibration.
All of your senses overlap to a
substantial degree and if one of them is
missing,
it's perfectly reasonable for the others
to occupy the territory that's,
that would otherwise be given over to
that sense.
And this actually has some practical
implications.
Even so silent reading is actually a
relatively new ability,
evolutionarily speaking.
I'm certainly.
Literacy is a relatively new invention
from an evolutionary perspective about
two to silent read is to use your eyes
as ears so you know when you read
silently you could hear the word,
so to speak in your head.
And the reason for that as it turns out,
is that the part of the brain that you
use to read silently with is right
between the visual and the auditory
cortex.
This right where they overlap.
So you are literally literally,
you are using your eyes,
ears and so that's quite the thing that
you can.
You can figure out how to do that.
So anyways,
so you can think about these
hypothalamic systems being in place more
or less ready to go at birth and then
having to organize themselves into a
sophisticated and integrated single ego
that acts across time and in the social
environment.
And you know,
when Piaget originally started talking
about child development,
he regarded the child as something that
was born into the world with just a set
of very primordial reflexes.
Mostly sucking reflex is and some
primary motor reflexes.
He was a very much a constructionist,
but I would say,
you know,
had he been alive now,
his constructionism,
would it be modified and modified by the
relevant neurophysiological data showing
that there's a lot more built into us
right from the beginning.
Then Piaget expected you still might
need experienced to catalyze the
development,
but obviously children are born with the
ability to hear and to see and to sense
with touch and they're hungry and tired
and angry and like they have the whole
range of emotions at hand and they also
come into the world with their
motivation already in place.
Otherwise you wouldn't be able to form a
relationship with them.
And that's modified by the development
of the higher cortical systems through
play and through social negotiation,
but the biology is there to begin with
and so that's.
That's a.
that's a good way to think about it with
regards to understanding how these,
how both,
how the fundamental biological systems
operate and how they manifest themselves
in in personality and in story because
you do that all the time.
You tell a story about how you got angry
and it's basically a story about being
dominated by a particular kind of
subpersonality which would be
hypothalamic and exactly how you
manifested that in what the consequences
were.
And you know I was very mad at this
person,
but I knew I couldn't get too upset
because.
And that's a good story.
That indicates both highly motivated
nature of the original response tendency
and then your immediate proclivity to
have to figure out how to negotiate that
expression within the social space so
that the medium to longterm consequences
are positive rather than negative.
And people are very interested in such
bits of information.
She sent such units of information
because we need to know how to conduct
ourselves in complex environments and so
if someone's willing to share their
experience and they can narrate it in an
interesting story,
we're absolutely more than happy to
listen because in some sense we're
assembling our identities out of those
stories and then you can think that
there are patterns across stories,
which is really a useful thing to
understand because what that gives you
real insight into what constitutes an
archetype,
because an archetype is what's common
across sets of stories.
That might be one way of looking at it.
So an archetype is like a Meta story and
so what part of what we're going to turn
to now in this discussion is a
description of certain metta stories and
there's a particular Metta story that
I'm most interested in.
That's the story about how stories
transformed themselves and so that's
that I think is the most fundamental
story that that,
that characterizes human beings.
There is the story I was,
here I am implemented some behaviors,
and I went there.
There was better than here.
That's the fundamental unit,
but the thing about structures like that
is that they may work in one situation
and not in another or at one time and
not in another and thus they have to be
modified and it was partly for this
reason that piaget has his career as a
developmental psychologist progressed,
started to understand that it was more
important,
not so much to understand the given
structure of a knowledge structure,
but to understand the manner in which
knowledge structures transformed and
that was partly partly illustrated in
his description of stage theory because
stages,
we're really movement from one set of
axiomatic presuppositions.
That through through,
through with which the child was
structuring the world into a state where
that system failed because it wasn't
sufficiently comprehensive and then into
the development of a new stage that
could do everything.
The previous stage could plus account
for all the things that the previous
stage couldn't.
So that's also why Piaget believed that
knowledge actually accumulated because
each time there was a transformation,
the new structure could had a wider
range of application than the previous
structure.
Even though it kept all the advantages
of the previous structure and so that's
a good way of.
That's a good way of conceptualizing
progress because it's not that easy.
If you're a relativist.
Fundamentally you don't believe in
difference between knowledge structure
say,
and you certainly don't believe in the
idea of progress,
but if you think about a more
sophisticated structure as being able to
do more things properly,
then you can certainly map out progress
with no problem and you know you know
that because you see people operating
the world who are less competent,
generally speaking and more competent
generally speaking,
and there doesn't seem to be much debate
about that.
You can recognize people like that very,
very easily.
So.
So that's the basic structure and we've
talked about that at length and I
suggested that while you're occupying a
structure like that,
the world manifests itself to you not as
objects,
but as number one.
Things to ignore,
which is the major category.
I was talking to some guy yesterday who
is working pinky was in San Diego on
artificial intelligence and neural
networks and he.
He was working with someone who's
actually started to a neural network
work.
We'll learn how to weight certain
stimulus features,
let's say in order to identify an image,
so the thing will be trained up on a
whole set of diverse images and it
learns through feedback to discriminate
between them,
but the problem with the neural network
is that it's not easy to understand
what's actually going on inside of them
because it sells itself generated so we
could easily end up,
for example,
creating fully conscious machines and
not understanding at all how they work.
That's the most likely outcome in my
estimation.
But this guy was working with another
guy who had figured out how to model the
weights and one of the things he told me
was that a tremendous amount of what the
neural network is doing is learning
what's not relevant.
Right?
Which is exactly what.
And these,
by the way,
these neural network models produce
output that's analogous to the output
that's produced by sections of cortical
tissue.
It's not identical,
but so partly they make the same kind of
mistakes,
which is an indication that they're
functioning in the same way,
so one of the things that have neural
net does when you're training it is
learned to figure out which things it
can ignore and that's mostly what you're
doing is what can be ignored.
And that's a tremendous realization too
because it.
It highlights again how important the
structure within which you exist,
what,
how importantly the structure within
which you exist determines what
manifests itself to you as you move
through the world because you ignore
almost everything so you ignore almost
everything,
but then you concentrate on things that
move you along your way or obstacles
that get in your way and those things
have emotional significance there.
Valence,
and the reason their valence is because
there are conceptualized in relationship
to the journey.
You know,
if you run across a tool or something
positive,
an opportunity we could say,
which is like an abstract tool,
then that moves you forward and the fact
that it's moving you forward is signaled
by the incentive reward system.
Dopaminergic mediated incentive reward
system.
That's grounded in the Hypothalamus,
the same system that you use when you
explore the same system that's activated
by psychomotor stimulants like cocaine
and heroin and most of the drugs that
people abuse,
that that system indicates to you that
this entity is non ignorable because
it's positively,
functionally related to the
transformation of the world that you're
attempting to accomplish,
so that makes you happy.
It makes you that,
that that provides you with with hope
and incentive to move forward.
If fundamental,
motivating force of life for human
beings with the possible exception,
say of aggression and sexuality,
which I would say operate much more
sporadically.
This is pretty much continual and then
of course the negative emotions are
generated when you encounter something
that gets in the way which can require a
small detour,
let's say,
or can blow apart the frame that you're
inhabiting completely.
And part of what we're trying to do is
understand how you compute,
how emotional to get about about certain
classes of events.
And the reason that it's so complicated
is because often when you run into a.
When you run into a tool or an
opportunity,
generally speaking,
it's not too hard to compute how useful
it is,
although sometimes something can happen
to you.
Like let's say you win a lottery where
the possibility space is so great that
it's an indefinite positive
significance.
You know,
when you're going to be overwhelmed by
that sort of thing.
It's pretty rare that something like
that happens,
but it does happen to it.
Maybe it happens when someone that
you're desperately chasing for Amaris
purposes agrees to go out with you.
That's another place where that sort of
excitement occurs.
It seems to occur to football players,
you know,
when they make a touchdown on tv too,
because they do their little touchdown
dance around like mad dogs and you know,
scientists never do that when they get
out of paper published.
So there's something about scoring a
goal that's really got that incentive
reward blast,
you know.
So anyhow,
um,
the positive emotion systems are
operating roughly speaking because you
have encountered something that moves
you forward on your path.
And we could say that given as we've
discussed,
that your,
your value structure is a nested entity,
right?
With small goals,
nested inside larger goals or small
personalities,
nested inside of larger personalities,
a positive thing that's really positive
has implications for what you're doing
right now that are positive but also has
positive implications higher up the
abstraction chain,
you know.
So for example,
let's say you study really hard for an
exam and you get a really good grade on
it and you're surprised,
you think,
well,
that's extraordinarily useful.
I passed the grade,
I passed the exam,
I did well in the course,
but that means that maybe I'm a better
student than I thought,
and given what I'm aiming for in the
future,
maybe I'm a more competent person that I
had believed.
And so you can see that the positive
emotion with echo through those levels
of analysis because it has implications
on each level.
Now you're also trying,
when you encounter something negative to
constrain its propagation across those
levels,
because let's say you study really hard
and you fail a dismally and so then you
think,
well,
I,
I messed up this course,
I've messed up this exam,
I messed up this course.
I'm not as good as student as I think I
am.
Maybe I'm a failure as a person and
that'll.
That can take you out completely.
Right,
and of course there are more.
There are certainly more traumatic
events that can be fall you than that a
typical one that really will wipe
someone out.
Imagine someone who's naive and
dependent and over sheltered.
No,
and they and so they're off into the
world,
although they're not prepared it and you
know they're,
they're axiomatic presuppositions aren't
sophisticated enough to allow for the
existence of radical uncertainty or
malevolence and then one day they're
attacked when they're,
maybe they're out,
they get mugged or maybe they get raped
or something worse,
and they develop posttraumatic stress
disorder from that.
And the reason for that is that the
event is so anomalous,
especially combined with its malevolence
that it demolishes the interpretation
frames from the local level all the way
out to the superordinate level,
and then the person is cast into this
chaotic state and they're terrified and
angry and vengeful and and paralyzed and
depressed and and all of those things
simultaneously.
And maybe they never put the pieces back
together,
right?
They descend into chaos and that's that.
And if you're in a situation like that
long enough,
you know the cortisol that's produced
can produce permanent neurophysiological
changes,
shrinkage of the hippocampus,
which is the part of the brain that
moves information from short term
attention to longterm storage,
shrinkage of the hippocampus and growth
of the Amygdala,
which is something that seems to tag
stimuli roughly speaking with emotional
significance,
more or less permanently,
right?
Because if you really encountered
something traumatic,
the hippocampus restricts information
with regards to its application in this
certain time and place.
So it's sort of situation specific.
But if you encounter something truly
dangerous,
your brain is set up so that you will be
afraid of it.
Rep,
regardless of context,
so it's called the Amygdala,
can peruse context,
independent fears and those are those
are basically,
while they can be part of posttraumatic
stress disorder,
they can be part of a,
a very,
very serious phobia and so you can't
contextualize them.
What you really do with someone who has
a problem like that as you try to walk
them through a recontextualization
process so you know maybe if they're
afraid of snakes,
so afraid of them,
they can't even really think of snakes.
You have the well first,
maybe you have them sit for one second
and think of a cartoon snake,
you know,
and what happens is their brain notices
that they can hold that image and
nothing negative happens and so then
it's that in some sense it's built in
inhibitory structure that partially that
partially inhibits which is what
inhibitory structures do.
That partially inhibits the otherwise
context independent fear that would
constitute the phobia.
And so you basically build up contexts
of safety around the phobia until the
context signifies lack of danger in the
person can progress forward if they're
really damaged.
It's really hard to do that,
especially if the trauma was really
severe,
so okay,
so you see you don't see irrelevant
things.
That's most things you do.
See things that move you forward and you
do see things that get in your way and
in the class of things that get in your
way are in determinant occurrences,
novel or anomalous occurrences,
and almost everything that gets in your
way is in some sense a novel occurrence
because you usually structure your
behavior so that you don't go anywhere
where something wildly anomalous is
likely to occur.
So,
so not if you encountered an obstacle to
things happening at the same time and
one is that your movement forward to
your specific goal or sets of goals is
blocked.
But the second thing that happens is
you're faced with a mystery and the
mystery is this thing wasn't supposed to
exist,
but it does exist.
So what implication does that have for
everything?
I think,
and that's very,
very hard on people.
They do not like that at all and no
wonder because it's,
it's,
it's the constrained chaos that's
underneath everything inhibited by your
contextual knowledge that suddenly
popped its head up into your world.
It's like it's like the shark in the
movie jaws,
which is of course a mythological story.
It's exactly that and,
and,
and it's,
it's exactly what that movie signified,
a safe vacation paradise all of a sudden
threatened by some subterranean thing
that can pull you down and,
and that destroys the peace and the
harmony of that particular community to
dragon story.
It's a hero myth.
It's,
it's the story that people have been
telling forever.
So,
so,
and what you can think,
you can think of that thing that
re-emerges,
that shark that rises up from the depths
or that whale or that dragon or that
Predator or,
or the foreign invader for that matter
or the barbarian,
they all fit into the same category.
That's what had been deemed irrelevant
suddenly manifesting itself.
And when you think about how much is
deemed irrelevant,
the fact that it's suddenly manifest
itself,
that's exactly the purpose for the
reason for the,
for the trauma,
it's like,
well,
I've,
I've eradicated from my
conceptualizations,
99 point nine,
nine percent of everything.
It's zeroed out and all of a sudden I've
made a mistake,
bang,
I don't know where I am.
Well,
what's relevant when you don't know
where you are.
And the answer to that is,
since you don't know everything is
relevant and you can imagine the sort of
terror that people who experienced
paranoid schizophrenia are living in
perennially because what happens to them
is precisely that they undergo
neurophysiological transformations that
makes everything,
that they once dependent on disappear
and everything comes back is relevant
and that puts them in the early stages
of schizophrenia.
That's extraordinarily stressful,
neurophysiologically.
So they're overwhelmed with cortisol and
their brains do deteriorate as a
consequence of that is just too much so
on,
surprisingly right?
Because you can't deal with.
You can hardly deal with anything,
let alone with everything.
Now and often,
what you see,
and it's rarely conceptualized this way
in the training of,
of of clinical therapists,
but often what you see when you are
dealing with people who are in crisis
isn't people who have a mental illness.
In fact,
in my experience,
that's actually quite rare.
What's far more common is that the
person that you're talking to has become
overwhelmed by catastrophe so their life
has fallen apart in some way that makes
what they're doing actually impossible.
You know,
so maybe someone very close to them in
their family that they were depending on
has developed a very serious illness and
that's throwing their entire financial
state into utter chaos.
Or maybe they've developed a condition
that makes it impossible for them to
work.
Or you know you can.
You can imagine the potential range of
catastrophes and they're coming to see
you because they're anxious and
depressed.
But the reason they're anxious and
depressed is because everything they
have ignored has popped its head back up
and is hell bent on their destruction.
And often you see people who are being
attacked by five or six of these
monsters out at the same time and it
isn't their mental illness that stops
them from being able to deal with it,
although that,
you know,
whatever weaknesses you have are going
to interfere.
It's the fact that what they're facing
is no damn joke.
And if you were facing it,
you'd feel exactly the same way.
So then you're trying to come up with
practical solutions to these
tremendously complex problems.
And that's a very,
a very well,
it's extraordinarily difficult.
Generally speaking,
people often don't come to a therapist
until they've exhausted their entire
range of resources.
They cannot figure out what to do.
And so,
you know,
in a situation like that you can
administer antidepressants and maybe
that'll help the person increase their
stress resistance.
But as a,
uh,
and it may be that because they're
depressed and have been brought down,
that they are in fact exaggerated the
danger of some of the smaller monsters
that are after them.
But making the person more stress
resilient doesn't give them,
for example,
a new job.
And it certainly doesn't bring back the
person they've been living with for two
years who has a degenerating
neurological disease or some form of
cancer.
Like these things are major.
You know,
I often see people who while they were
in a relationship,
maybe they're rather isolated,
older,
older people,
one of the partners is dying in their
entire financial situation has become
catastrophic.
It's like that's not a mental illness
man.
I mean they may have got into that
situation because of one inadequacy or
another,
but you don't even want to push that too
far because that sort of thing can
happen to anyone and and will in fact
happen to most people in one form or
another at least at some point in their
lives.
So you want to be damned prepared for
that.
You want to be prepared for that because
it's bitter and harsh and anxiety
provoking and painful.
But if you're not ready that it's also
hell.
And often you can stop things from
becoming hell even though you can't stop
them from being bitter and painful and
anxiety provoking and all of that.
You can at least delimit the catastrophe
enough.
So that it doesn't permanently bring you
in,
the people around you down.
And that's not so bad,
right?
That's a hell of.
Or at least it's a lot better than the
alternative.
So this is the problem.
You know,
things object things are obstacles.
Well,
how big is the obstacle?
It's the same.
It's the same question is how big is the
Predator that's lurking outside the door
of our cave?
It's exactly the same problem except
construct,
conceptualized abstractly,
and,
and I would say exactly the same systems
that you're distant ancestors used to
conceptualize the lurking Predator are
the systems that are activated now when
you encounter the reemergence of all the
monsters that you've ignored,
it's the same neurological platform you
think,
well,
how could it be otherwise?
Because evolution is a conservative
process.
Everything about you is built on an
ancient foundations,
right?
Very little new.
Certainly very little radically new
comes into existence.
It's mostly tinkering with structures
that have been around forever.
Like your body plan,
for example.
That's unbelievably old.
I mean you share that with.
You share that with lizards,
roughly speaking.
So it's incredibly ancient.
So you know when you share a bilateral
symmetry,
even with most invertebrates,
so those,
those things are extraordinarily old and
so for our,
for our ancestors,
what was down out of the tree,
let's say down in the grass,
that was the thing that lurked in the
unknown.
Well for us,
the idea of the unknown has become much
more abstractly conceptualized like we
can think of the unknown as such things
we don't know and so then we can think
of the abstract Predator and abstract.
Predator is the thing that lurks in the
unknown that always confronts us now
because people are strange and complex
creatures and because we're partly
predators and partly prey animals,
we don't only conceptualize the thing
that lurks in the unknown as a,
as a devouring predator.
We also conceptualize it as something
that offers possibility it because we've
learned that if we go into the unknown,
we can find things that we need for,
for,
for now and for the medium and for the
long term.
It can be beneficial for us to confront
the things that we don't know.
And that's human beings.
In a nutshell.
That's what we do,
and so that's the basis,
that's the,
that's why I believe that's the most
archetypal story because it
fundamentally characterizes our motive
being in the world where information
foragers,
we'd go out into the unknown,
that terrifying unknown and we gather
things of value.
It's not much different than squirrels
foraging for nuts really,
you know,
it's,
and we use the exactly the same
biological systems to go out and forage
for information that squirrels use when
they go out and forage for nuts.
So I guess the system developed in part
because we were fruit eaters as well and
so we found trees that had fruit in them
and learn where they were and how to
gather them.
And then you see a tight relationship
there between and food,
right.
There's almost no difference between
eating and knowing where the food is and
as soon as the.
So our systems of knowing where things
are grew massively and so that turned us
into the kind of abstract creatures that
we are.
So we're always looking for ways of
producing more of what we need.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And we do that abstractly,
so alright,
so when you encounter something that's
anomalous,
something unexpected,
so oh,
you're in a relationship that you're not
that happy about,
it's a good example,
and the person that you're with is
suddenly much colder to you than usual.
Okay?
Now the question is,
is that good news or bad news?
And the answer is,
well,
it's good news in so far as you're not
that happy with the relationship,
so it's.
And it's bad news in so far as you want
the relationship to continue and so very
frequently it's the case that you're
somewhat ambivalent about the frame that
you inhabit.
And so anomalous information has a
twofold meaning.
It's like,
well,
now I can finally get out of this.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And,
and if the person is particularly cold
and distant to you and maybe even
insulting,
then half of you is going to be very
upset because this is happening and the
other half is roughly speaking,
is going to be saying,
oh,
this is just the opportunity I wanted.
And what that means is you're in your
frame.
That constitutes the relationship.
Let's say in the story you've laid out
about it,
that novel event occurs and it produces
activation in two competing systems.
One is the positive system that explores
for new opportunities and the other is
the threat system that paralyzes you
because your current mode of
conceptualization is no longer valid and
so it normally has this deeply
ambivalent nature and one of the things
that I've tried to understand for a long
time is how you compute that and it
seems to be that you need to consider it
in relationship to this hierarchical
value structure that we've talked about
before.
So you might say that imagine your
nervous system is tuned so that if
anomalous things happen at high
resolution levels,
you,
you produce a very small amount of
negative emotion and a comparatively
large amount of curiosity.
Because the thing that's being
threatened by the anomalous event isn't
that big.
And so the.
The possibility that information looks
there.
That might be useful as high compared to
the threat.
Whereas generally speaking,
if you encounter something,
maybe you know,
maybe you go into a store one day and on
a whim,
you shoplift something.
In a fit of stupid impulsivity and you
get caught at,
happened to,
uh,
there was an NDP member of parliament 20
years ago who did exactly that.
He only had a pretty good reputation.
He went into a department store,
swiped something,
some gloves or something.
I don't even remember what it was and
caught.
It's like,
well,
you know,
that's sufficiently anomalous behavior
to or occurrence to make you question
whether or not you're actually a good
person.
And so it's,
it's almost as if at the higher
resolution levels of the value structure
of something anomalous occurs,
then it's either neutral or tilted
slightly towards positive and at the
higher levels and the more abstract and
comprehensive levers.
If something anomalous happens,
then it,
it's more likely to blow out large
portions of your,
of the systems you use to organize the
world.
It's going to be experienced as
negative.
And partly what you're trying to do when
something anomalous occurs is to do a
search up and down this value of
structure.
You have an argument with someone that
you love,
well,
what does that mean?
Maybe you're arguing about how you
interact with each other.
When one of you comes home,
you'd like a kiss and a hug at the door
and they've just assumed sit there and
watch tv,
so you have an argument about that.
Okay.
What is the argument mean?
Does it mean that some little thing has
to be adjusted at the level of micro
detail or does it mean you know the
person that you've tangled up your life
with really doesn't care for you at all
and there's a complete jerk and you
should leave?
While a big part of the argument is
going to be how do we construe the
occurrence?
How do we construe the occurrence?
Is it a major event or a minor event?
And my advice would be unless there's
strong reason,
presume it's a minor event and start
operating at that level because
otherwise every argument becomes a
catastrophe and if that's the case,
you actually can't solve any problems.
You won't be able to discuss anything.
Right?
Because as soon as you bring up an
anomaly,
something unpleasant,
the other person,
we'll assume that everything's over and
get so shorted out that you won't be
able to talk with them.
So those are the sort of people who will
cry if you bring up anything negative.
Right?
And so they,
they're threatened by their,
their value might say their value
structure,
so fragile,
highly constructed,
and maybe they're not standing on enough
pillars so that anything you tossed at
them,
that's a question is enough to shake the
entire structure to its foundations or
maybe they're acting that out just to
manipulate you.
That's another option.
So in many ways,
partly what you seem to be doing when
you're thinking about something is to
shift your frames of reference up and
down your value hierarchy to constrain
the occurrence and to determine the
degree to which it's positive and the
degree to which it's negative.
It's also complicated too because
whether something is positive or
negative depends on the frame of
reference that you bring to bear on it.
Right?
And so that's why I was saying earlier
about the relationship.
If you're ambivalent about the
relationship and something negative
happens,
you know something disruptive,
it's certainly possible to adopt a frame
of reference almost immediately that
makes that into something positive.
You say,
well,
I'm was done with this anyways.
I'm glad you said that because it gives
me the excuse I needed to terminate
this,
and so it's such a.
it's a very strange thing that you can
shift the emotional valence of almost
anything,
almost anything.
By shifting your frame
of reference,
there are boundaries.
You can teach animals pleasure to
electric shocks,
painful electric shocks if you pair them
reliably,
lead with the provision of something
intensely rewarding cocaine,
for example,
or or hypothalamic stimulation,
they can learn to associate pain with
something good and respond positively to
it to work for it.
So when you see this in you even a
little bit,
some of you have no doubt.
Learn to eat foods that aren't really
edible like all of us are a good example
of that,
or coffee.
They're bitter and generally speaking,
better.
Poisonous things tend to be bitter and
people don't really like bitter things,
but if you train yourself you can get to
the point where I,
I taught my daughter how to eat olives
when she was very young and I,
I bet her,
I think,
I think she was only three.
I better that she couldn't eat 20 all of
over the next week or something.
She'd always respond to a challenge and
so,
you know,
the first three olives,
it was not a fun experience for her
because it faced a kids have a lot of
taste buds.
Her face would get all crinkled up and
she just wasn't enjoying it now.
But I paid for that desperately later in
my life because I used to go to this
specialty shop and buy these
particularly good spicy olives,
you know,
by the court.
And if they were in the fridge she'd
come home and just devoured the entire
court.
Like a,
like a,
like I'm a mad believe mic.
I mean on all of us for God's sake.
And so then I never got any of them so
it serves me.
Right,
exactly.
But the point is you can rewire yourself
quite completely by placing negative
things in a positive context.
And the degree to which you can do that
is quite remarkable.
You know,
you,
you can't.
There seems to be limits beyond which
your ability to turn pain into pleasure,
for example,
is compromised.
Um,
I don't think anybody's ever going to
learn how to associate being seriously
burnt by something hot with something
pleasurable,
right?
There's,
and I don't know how the system is
exactly adjust themselves so that there
are limits to,
you know,
how you can transform an emotional
stimulus because you can transform them
quite quite remarkably.
But obviously there's some boundaries
that we don't understand very well.
So.
All right,
so no.
So roughly speaking,
we could say that the degree to which
something is experienced as utter chaos
is proportionate to the level of the
value hierarchy that that anomalous
event is construed or experience to
disrupt.
And you really see this happening and
people who are depressed because you
might think,
here's another way of thinking about it.
You might think,
well,
I'm,
am I a good cook?
You're asking yourself,
you fail.
At cooking something so you think,
well,
am I capable of completing a meal and
you might say,
well,
if if all you've done is a set the table
badly,
probably the right thing to do is to
learn how to set the table and not to
question your ability to complete a
meal.
So then you might say,
okay,
well when should you move up one level
competence of one level of abstraction?
We might say,
well imagine there's five things that
you need to do at this level in order to
successfully complete that level.
So you have to cut vegetables,
you have to set the table,
you have to do the dishes in order to
complete a meal,
and so you break six dishes,
you burn the soup and I don't know,
but you sat the table property.
You got two out of three wrong,
or maybe at that point it started.
It's time to start wondering if you're
actually capable of completing a meal,
but you don't want to jump from a single
mistake at the higher level to the to
the or at the.
Sorry.
At the higher resolution level.
You don't want to jump from a single
mistake at that level to the next level,
and the reason for that is that you'll
get a cascade,
oh,
I set the table badly error.
That means I can't complete a meal
error.
That means I can't take care of my
family error.
That means I'm not a good parent error.
That means I'm not a good person.
That's what happens to depressed people
and I think what happens is their
serotonin levels fall right fall like,
like serotonin levels fall.
If you're brought down a dominance
hierarchy,
now we already know that if you live at
the bottom of the dominance hierarchy,
you live where it's dangerous and the
reason for that is everything around you
is already not good and you don't have a
lot of social support,
so you're sort of clinging desperately
to the underside of life,
and what that means is you probably
can't even afford a single mistake.
Your serotonin levels fall and that
allows error signals to propagate up the
value system so that every little thing
becomes a catastrophe.
Now that in itself is a catastrophe
because if you're living at the bottom
of the dominance hierarchy and you're
already super stressed,
the additional stress that you're likely
to experience as a consequence of an
additional error is going to be maybe
push you over the limits,
but the thing is is that it is dangerous
there.
Now,
what seems to happen to people who are
depressed is that their serotonin levels
fall roughly speaking as if they
plummeted down a dominance hierarchy
without have actually having plumbing to
download it,
so they're still competent,
capable,
ensconced in their,
in their relatively productive
environment,
but they're reacting as if every little
thing has become a catastrophe.
And so partly what happens is if you
provide people with Serotonin reuptake
inhibitors,
is that the propagation of negative
emotion across these levels of value
hierarchy seems to be reduced.
So maybe then it takes,
if it takes two errors at this level to
trigger off an error message at that
level while you're in a lot better
shape,
right?
That's,
it's like a definition of resilience.
So now you can also do that with people
cognitively to some degree.
You know,
because maybe somebody will come to you
in therapy and say,
I had a bad day at work,
my boss hates me.
I'm going to lose my job,
and then my marriage is going to
dissolve,
and so you walk them through it at a
micro level.
Okay,
what exactly happened to you at work and
then they lay out the specific story.
You say,
well,
what are the multiple ways that might be
interpreted and is it,
is there some possibility that it's not
the catastrophe that you're envisioning?
Right?
You get them to contextualize it and
help them build out up micro defenses.
That might be one way of thinking about
it.
A lot of people who are prone to
depression are not good at defending
themselves,
right?
They don't have at hand the mechanisms
to forgive themselves or even really to
understand their own failure or even
more importantly sometimes
they unwrap,
likely underestimate.
They radically overestimate their own
incompetence and radically overestimate
the competence of everyone else,
and so that's also another reason why
it's sometimes useful for people to seek
therapy because they'll come in and say,
well,
I'm anxious and nervous and you know I
have this amount of negative emotion and
I make these sorts of mistakes,
and you listen and you think,
yeah,
so does everybody else that that's par
for the course,
but there are so isolated and so afraid
of the things that have been happening
to them and so unwilling to expose
themselves to social evaluation that
they never really communicate with
anyone else and find out that the level
of misery that characterized as their
existence is pretty much normal and
average,
and so just helping people learn that
can often be of tremendous advantage to
the because the real issue isn't
precisely whether or not you're a good
person.
That's an absolute idea,
right?
You could say,
well,
are you good person compared to the
absolute ideal?
And the answer to that is no,
but it's also not exactly.
It's not a useful comparison across most
situations.
What you really want to know is,
well,
how do you stack up against other
people?
You know,
if you're a.
If you're at your job,
the issue isn't whether or not you're
competent.
The issue is whether you're competent
compared to the other people around you
who are supposed to be doing the same
thing because in an absolute sense
you're completely incompetent,
but in a relative sense,
you might be at the top of the pack or
even in the middle,
and that's generally okay.
So,
and if you don't know what the relative
status is,
that's not good at all.
So alright,
now if so,
here's a way of thinking about it.
Let's say
you're in a class,
it's near the beginning of the semester.
You write an exam or you handed in an
essay and you don't get the mark that
you desired.
Okay?
So what are your options?
Well,
one option would be,
so you've hit an anomaly.
Things didn't happen the way you wanted
them to happen,
and so maybe you say,
Geez,
that was a boring and stupid class.
Anyways,
this gives me an excuse to get out.
And so that's not such a negative thing
or you think,
oh well I really better buckle down and
study and you decide to stay in the
class.
So basically what you've done is
maintained your framework.
I'm going to work through this class,
but you're,
you're,
you've decided to modify some of the sub
routines that make up that frame.
You say,
well I should study more next time or I
have to prioritize this class compared
to other classes.
So it's a micro alteration within the
overarching framework.
But another thing you can do is say to
hell with the class.
I just won't,
I'll just drop it.
And so the advantage to that is problem
gone.
The disadvantages,
well now you have a different problem
which is okay,
fine,
you drop the class,
do you have another class that you can
replace it with?
Is that a good way of dealing with a
micro failure,
you know,
to move up a level of analysis and
throughout the whole frame because you
could also say,
well maybe I should just drop out of
university and maybe I should go hang
myself.
You know,
that's.
Well,
it's the same line of logic,
it's just taken up to a higher degree of
abstraction and so generally speaking,
you don't want to solve a problem by
moving up a level in wiping out the
frame within which the problem was
experienced.
Do you want to do that carefully?
Because in principle,
the frame that you were working within
had already,
you'd already assigned value to it and
worked at it.
You've already invested in it.
It's a big sacrifice to blow out the
whole frame.
Now sometimes you can do it.
So anyways,
what happens is,
well,
you get the bad grade and you're upset
about it,
and so you've been plunged from your
happy,
satiated state,
let's say,
into a state of relative chaos,
and the chaos is,
oh,
I hit an obstacle,
I didn't expect it and now I don't know
what to do,
and so what does it mean to not know
what to do?
Well,
okay,
it can mean I need to study harder.
It can mean I should drop this course.
It can mean I should major in a
different subject.
I mean maybe I shouldn't be in
university.
It could mean maybe my future plans have
been formulated badly.
It can mean my future plans have been
formulated badly because I don't
understand myself very well and I've
been telling lies about my past.
Right?
The thing can really expand on you and
that's what the chaotic domain is.
That's the real manifestation of those
things that you had considered
irrelevant,
right?
Because when you go to pickup the exam,
you've got your identity as a competent
student intact.
You're not questioning whether you
should be in the course or whether you
should be in that major or whether you
should be in university.
None of that.
That's all in the implicitly accepted
category and as soon as the anomalous
event,
he merges all of those things that you
had rendered.
Axiomatic start to become questionable
and that's like the shark coming up out,
coming up from the depths to pull you
down.
And that's the classic way of of
representing that and symbolizing it.
That's Jonah and the whale for example.
So it's something is manifested itself
from the deep unknown and pulls you
under like an alligator at a,
at a waterhole,
which is I'm sure one of the sources
from which we derived that particular
kind of mythological representation,
because you could imagine that when we
were on the Velt,
after living on trees,
we had to go down to the dam waterholes
and you've,
you've watched enough nature programs to
know what a denial crocodile can do to a
water buffalo.
It's not pretty.
And so to go down to the water,
the chaotic water and the source of all
life as well,
right,
is to risk and encounter with the
terrible thing that lurks in the depths.
And so we use that as a central metaphor
for,
for mapping those sorts of things that
have happened to us in a much more
abstract space.
And you know that because one of the
things you're going to do,
let's say that the,
the,
the professor,
there's a professor obviously who gave
you the bad grade.
Okay?
So one logical presupposition is that
you're in some sense insufficient in
relationship to the course,
but another logical and instantaneous
categorization is to throw that person
into the category of malevolent
Predator.
And you'll do that by becoming upset and
cursing the person in your imagination.
Cursing is exactly right,
and I can tell you why,
so I don't know if I told you this or
not,
but primates of various sorts.
Like vervet monkeys have Predator alarm
cries.
They have one.
If you look across a vast array of
predators are primates.
They have one for things that attack
from the sky.
And so those would be predatory birds.
They have one for like cats that
climbing into the trees to get you.
And that means hit the hit the little
branches because the cat can't be out
there and they have one for a things
that Russell through the grass snakes
for example.
And so each of those produces a
distinctive alarm cry.
And so that's the same alarm.
That alarm Christ system is the same
system that we use to swear with you
short got her old words.
So they're archaic words because short
words tend to be very,
very old and so that's,
and we have a separate system that
others,
those sorts of vocalizations and that's
the system that's disinhibited and two
reps,
which is why people with tourette swear.
And so when you curse the professor for
giving you the bad grade,
you are using the same bloody linguistic
system that your ancestors used to
categorize snakes in the grass or
predators that sweep swooped down from
the sky.
It's very,
very interesting.
So when people regard that,
it's quite rude,
right?
If you,
if you swear at someone,
then they'll be taken aback by that they
considered insulting to be thrown into
the arbitrary Predator category.
And so that also turns the world into a
good versus evil story very rapidly with
the,
with the oppressive person who's judging
you,
playing the role of malevolent Predator
and you playing the role of innocent,
innocent pray essentially very,
very easy for that to happen.
So,
okay,
so where's my little clicker?
So if the anomaly,
if you can't can,
you might say,
okay,
so you're thinking through the fact that
you didn't get a good mark on the exam
and you think,
oh,
I don't know what I can do about that
because I've already got six classes say
or seven.
Maybe you're overloaded,
you're working part time,
you're studying as hard as you can,
and so you try to do a micro
six,
rearranging your priorities,
concentrating more on your studies,
but maybe you're already operating at
top capacity and it's not easy.
It's not straightforward for you to
calculate how you might reconstruct your
micro priority so the problem goes away.
So it's under those circumstances that
it's reasonable to pop up one level of
abstraction and to say,
okay,
I have to give something up.
That's a sacrificial motifs.
I have to sacrifice something.
What's it going to be?
Well,
maybe you can't afford to have the part
time job even though that's going to put
you under financial stress.
Or maybe you have to hire a tutor even
though that's going to put you under
financial stress.
Or maybe you have to drop out of the
chorus and only takes six,
even though that's going to say delay
your graduation for one semester.
They're gonna.
There's going to be costs,
but so what's happening when you're
thrown into the chaotic state by the
anomaly is that the problem space,
Matt magnifies itself and you have to do
a microanalysis,
which is the best place to start.
Let's look at fixing things that are
subordinate to this frame,
but you may have to leap up a level or
two and fix something.
It's Super Ordinance,
so it may be the case that you failed
two classes and your parent,
one of your parents develops a very
fatal disease and so you have to go home
and take care of them.
It's like,
okay,
fine.
Too much chaos.
Bang,
you're done with your university career.
For now,
you have to go up a number of levels,
blow apart that frame,
and that'll alleviate the problem.
Even though it by,
by letting all the snakes out of the
basket,
it causes all sorts of other problems.
You're going to have to think,
okay,
well what am I going to do instead?
What does this mean for my future and so
forth,
so there's a cost.
There's definite cost to moving up the
abstraction hierarchy,
but the reason that a sufficient to
normally put places you in chaos is
because it makes all sorts of things
that you've already considered alive
again,
and that can be extraordinarily chaotic
and so you,
the anomaly knocks you flat.
You can sustain the frame anymore.
You plunge into a chaotic state and you
know your life.
Your whole life is a sequence of those
things at a micro level and at a macro
level,
you know every time you encounter
something you don't understand.
You have to retool the framework of
interpretation that you were using prior
to encountering that.
Now sometimes it's just a small
modification,
like at least in principle when you were
in a class and you're learning things,
you're undoing what you already knew and
reese and sewing back together
constantly,
but it's at a small enough level so that
maybe it only feels exhilarating,
right?
You're releasing just enough novelty to
activate your exploratory systems
because there's value in the
information,
but not enough to knock you flat and you
know,
one of the things that's interesting
about the whole safe space phenomenon is
that people differ in the thresh hold
that they have with regards to the
receipt of anomalous information.
You know,
and and if you're,
especially if you're a naive person and
the sheltered person to be exposed to
anything that has a hint of real
malevolence in it might be enough to
destabilize you quite badly and that's a
real problem if you're pursuing
education in history or literature
because history and literature is
nothing but a sequence of absolute moral
catastrophes thrown at you one after the
other,
so you have to be pretty solid to be
able to withstand that.
So you collapsed from your stable state
into an unstable state and that's where
everything comes up to haunt you.
Now it can really be bad in a chaotic
state because this often also happens to
people who are depressed,
but it can happen to people under normal
circumstances too.
It's like,
well,
let's say you've been happily married or
you think you were happily married,
and then one day you come home and your
partner is gone.
Well then what do you think?
Well,
you think mlevel and Predator,
that's one thing you think useless.
You.
That's another thing.
You think
the past is unstable.
The president is unstable and the future
is unstable.
That's another thing,
but then things can really get out of
hand.
So then you're just in chaos,
let's say,
but then you start thinking at 3:00
in the morning about all the stupid
things you've done in your life that led
you to this point and that can just take
you completely apart because you know,
if you go back over your past
experiences,
your,
it's easy for you to remember because
people do remember these things where
you made errors,
right?
And maybe you're not torturing yourself
to begin with about the specific errors
that you made in that relationship.
Although you probably will,
you know,
you'll think,
oh well,
you know,
I kind of knew this was coming and then
your mind will say,
well,
you kind of knew when it started and
then it'll tell you,
well,
maybe you should have done this back
then and you actually knew it and you'll
think,
yeah,
I actually did know it and I didn't do
it.
And then that'll trigger off a whole
host of other memories about just
exactly what you knew and didn't act on
and that'll trigger off a bunch of other
memories about stupid things that you've
made and mistakes that you've hidden and
make you question just exactly what sort
of creature you are and why all your,
how all your moral insufficiencies
defined by yourself have led you to this
dismal state.
And there's very little difference
between that and hell.
And so there's a mythology of the
underworld,
right?
The underworld is partly a place of and,
and that's a place where people go when
things fall apart.
But part of that is there's a
subdivision in chaos,
the tail and that subdivision is the
place that you go.
When you take yourself apart because of
your recognition of your own moral
failings,
now that can be useful because maybe you
have some things to learn and likely you
do,
but it can also be something that's so
devastating that you just can't recover
from so because you may conclude,
well,
the reason my relationship collapsed
precipitously is because I'm so blind in
malevolent that there's absolutely no
hope for my recovery,
and you know sometimes that's actually
true,
so distinguishing you never know,
right?
Is when things happen to you that aren't
what you want or expect.
It's an open question,
how much you're responsible for it.
Now,
a conscientious person under those
circumstances,
we'll just take themselves apart because
the conscientious person is liable to
presume that if something bad happens to
them,
it's because they did something wrong
and you can see that's useful.
If something bad happened to you because
you did something wrong and you can
learn what you did wrong and fix it,
then the bad thing won't happen to you
again.
So Hooray.
It's a wonderful way of thinking,
but it's very tricky because there is a
random element to life and sometimes you
get knocked flat by circumstances that
are really beyond any reasonable
person's control and this happens to
conscientious people.
For example,
when they get laid off on mass at work,
you know their company starts to fail.
The thousand people are laid off sort of
arbitrarily.
Some of those people are truly
industrious and conscientious even
though there is very little relationship
between their work habits and the
consequences for their job can
continuity.
They'll go home and brood about it and
take themselves apart and those are the
people who end up catastrophic,
really depressed because they can't
stand not being in a situation where
they're functional and productive.
So nasty.
So you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a cognitive response that can be
very useful,
but it's actually only useful when it is
what you did that resulted in that end
and not merely the blind random forces
of nature happening to focus on you.
And that's also a problematic issue too
because you know there's actually some
relief and concluding that it's your
fault because the alternative is that it
just happened,
right?
And that means that there are whole
swaths of terrible things that might
happen to you that are completely beyond
your control.
So it's not like deciding that you
weren't at fault leaves you in leaves,
you sitting pretty.
It just says,
well,
you weren't brought to your knees
because of your own stupidity and
malevolence.
Instead you were brought to your knees
by the absolute uncaring forces of
society and nature.
It's like,
well,
that's not much of a constellation.
I wouldn't say.
Although sometimes it's exactly the
right thing to conclude and
it is part of,
I think being mature to understand that
you are prey to random forces and you
need to be able to distinguish between
when you're at fault from something and
when something just happened to you.
And I would also say that the right rule
of thumb is to start with the assumption
that something just happened to you and
only then start to investigate the
degree to which you had something to do
with it.
Situational analysis,
first,
personal analysis.
Second,
it's safer because if you start with the
first one,
you'll take yourself apart morally,
continually.
And that's very,
very,
very stressful.
You should leave that for emergencies.
So okay,
so down you are in chaos,
right?
And so that's part of the classic human
story.
That classic human story is I was going
from point a to point B and I wanted to
get to point b and here's how I did it.
But then along the way something popped
up unexpectedly and stopped me and it
threw me for a loop.
It,
everything fell apart.
That's another metaphorical way of
representing it.
Everything fell apart and I didn't know
up from down,
right?
I lost myself.
It was like I was wandering in a desert
and that it lasted for years.
And that's a situation where people are
also likely to turn into such things as
alcohol and other drugs,
alcohol,
particular to being a good one because
it suppresses anxiety and increases
incentive reward,
and so down there in a chaotic state,
you can medicate yourself and you'll be
inclined to to you think,
well,
there's no hope for the future.
For example,
I can't see any way out of this.
While under those circumstances,
what else do you have to turn to?
So very.
That's to be in the belly of the whale.
That's another way of thinking about it.
You Remember in the Pinocchio Story,
that's where Japan Eto ended up,
and that was because he had severed his
relationship with the exploratory hero.
That was.
That was Pinocchio,
or lost the relationship.
You could call that an involuntary
encountered with the dragon of chaos
out.
Really what it is is that,
and that's it's.
It's your home happy and the Predator
invades your layer.
That's the story of
the garden of Eden.
God,
it's the story of the garden of Eden.
There's no place that's so safe that
there isn't a snake in it,
right?
It's the fundamental story of mankind,
even God himself can't define a space so
tightly and absolutely that a Predator
can't.
The Predator of the unknown can't make
itself manifest within.
Now,
I read a book here a while back
on dragons was only a week or two ago.
I just found this book.
It was published in 2002 and the,
Oh,
it's an book.
It's flawed,
but it's an interesting book.
I'll find the name of it for you,
but they,
the person who wrote this book was very
interested in the fact that
representations of dragons can be found
worldwide.
Really,
like no matter where you go,
that representation seems to exist.
It's the wings.
It's the winged legged serpent,
and he was very interested in trying to
puzzle out why and he had an interesting
hypothesis and I do believe there's some
truth to it.
He said like in the case of the vervet
monkeys,
that there were three class of predators
on tree dwelling primates,
winged bodied like a cat,
because cats in particular like to eat
tree dwelling primates and snakes.
So you might think,
well,
cats,
birds of prey and predatory and snakes
are all different,
but then you might think,
well what do you mean by different?
Exactly.
Because categories are constructed in
relationship to their functional
significance.
They're all the same if the categories,
things that eat you if you're not
careful,
and so there's absolutely no reason for
human beings not to have produced a
category that's an exemplar of things
that eat you if you're not careful.
And so it's an amalgam snake,
predatory cat,
predatory bird,
winged serpent with lakes,
right?
And often it has claws.
You see the clause on it,
on this one are like telethons and
they're often like that in dragon
representations or sometimes they're
more like the claws of predators,
but the talent representation is quite
common.
Often like this one,
the thing has two legs,
like a bird.
Not always because sometimes dragons
don't have any legs at all.
They're.
They're mostly snakes with wings and
sometimes they have four legs,
but they often also have two legs and so
you think you need a representation of
Predator.
You don't need a differentiated
representation precisely of type of
Predator.
That would come second.
You know,
it's like the kid who points out the cat
little kid points at the cat walking
down the street says doggy.
It's like,
that's not a dog.
no,
that's not right.
The child's use of dog isn't
representation of dog.
It's representation of four legged pedal
entity and cat is an exemplar of that
category and so his dog and so it bunny
rabbit for that matter and you might
say,
well,
so that's the category of pet and it's a
perfectly reasonable category.
You could say you should differentiate
it into bunny rabbit,
dog and cat because there's important
information lost in the low
representation representation of pet,
but there's a bloody useful information
conserved now,
so that's the wall garden and the dragon
of chaos.
I'm going to tell you something
interesting about genesis,
about the story in genesis.
This took me like 30 years to figure
out.
I could not figure it out for the
longest period of time.
It's a segue,
but it'll give you an idea of how these
things operate across vast spans of
time,
so in the,
in the garden of Eden,
Adam and Eve,
right?
The primordial human beings and there's
a walled garden.
That's paradise.
Paradise means walled garden.
An Eden means well watered place and so
there's this idea that the proper
habitat of human beings is an amalgam of
social structure and now and nature,
and that's exactly right because that's
what we live in,
right?
We live in a.
We never live in nature and we never
live in society.
We live in an amalgam of society and
nature.
That's the human environment.
So it's a walled garden.
All right,
and so it's a productive well-watered
place where we could thrive.
It's safe,
and it's ruled over by a father figure
in this particular,
in this particular story,
and that's like the.
You could think about that as the spirit
of civilization.
That's at least one way of considering
it so well.
There's a snake in the garden and it's
there.
Unbeknownst to God,
roughly speaking,
although he's.
He knows everything,
so I guess he probably knows about the
snake to and he tells Adam and Eve not
to interact with it and find and they
do,
and the snake wakes them up,
right,
because when they interact with the
snake,
they're given a fruit that opens their
eyes and makes them aware that they're
naked and vulnerable and then dooms them
to work well.
I'll tell you the whole story much later
in the course,
but I want to give you an overview of it
now,
but then there's this really strange
idea that developed over the course of
the development of not only Christianity
but Judaism and and a number of other
religions that fed into the mainstream
of Christian ideas including
zoroastrianism.
There's an idea that that emerged across
a very long period of time that the
snake in the garden was the same as
Satan.
The source of all evil,
and as I've been trying to figure out
for the longest period of time,
why in the world the manifestation of
what's essentially a representation of a
predator.
So that's the snake and the snake is
associated with trees.
Well,
yes.
The reason for that in all likelihood is
that we dwelt in trees,
right,
and snakes like trees and they're around
trees and they can climb trees and,
and the snake was a typical Predator on
our,
on our ancient relatives,
but.
And so that's fine.
So you can see that that representation
makes perfect sense.
There's predators that lurk in the
garden.
Yes.
Obviously if you interact with them,
they wake you up.
Well,
they better wake you up because if they
don't wake you up when you interact with
them,
then you get eaten.
So it's probably just as well to wake up
even though there's painful consequences
associated with becoming conscious.
And that manifests itself immediately in
the story of,
of,
of Adam and eve,
but then there's this weird association.
It's,
it's very undeveloped in the biblical
stories that,
that,
that are part and parcel of this line of
thinking.
It was more like a consequence of a
cloud of mythological stories that
surrounded it.
But the reason for that I think is,
is that imagine that what human beings
we're trying to puzzle out was the
nature of the Predator.
Okay.
So on one level of analysis,
the Predator is the thing that slinks
along the ground and the threatens you,
and also it's the thing that's your
mortal enemy and that wakes you up.
But then that's one conceptualization of
Predator and fair enough you can
identify it and you can take
precautionary measures,
but a better conceptualization of
Predator might be where does it come
from?
Let's say it's a snake,
while there's a layer of snake
somewhere.
And so if we want to get rid of the
snake,
we shouldn't be conceptualizing it as a
we should be conceptualizing it as one
manifestation of a layer of snakes.
And what we should do is go down,
follow the damn snake,
wherever it goes and find it's layer and
wipe out all of the snakes.
And that's,
that's a more abstract representation,
right?
It's not Predator anymore,
it's the source of predation.
And so if you want to solve the Predator
problem permanently,
you don't kill the snake,
you get rid of all the snakes.
Okay?
So fine.
So and people are pretty damn good at
that and that's why you have stories of
people like St Patrick who chased all
the snakes out of Ireland and all sorts
of saints were snake eradication saints
and well,
there's a variety of reasons for that.
But then you might think,
okay,
well the worst Predator is the layer of
snakes,
right?
But then you might think,
well wait a minute,
the worst Predator isn't the layer of
snakes.
Maybe the worst Predator is the enemies
that come to attack us.
And those are human enemies.
And so what we do is we defend ourselves
against the human enemies.
We put walls around our cities,
we fortify our,
our land,
and we defend ourselves against the evil
that's lurking in other people's hearts.
And so that's like a higher order snake.
And then we build these walls around us
and what's inside gets larger and larger
and larger.
And then what happens is the snake start
popping up inside the cities because you
know,
we pushed all the.
We've,
we've protected ourselves from all the
evil that lurks outside,
but we've now created a space where that
evil can manifest itself inside.
So there's criminals inside the city and
there's people who want to bring you
down and there's malevolence within the
city,
not only outside,
so then there's the problem of the snake
that's closer to you,
and then there's the ultimate problem,
which is the snake that lives in your
heart,
right?
And that each individual's capacity for
evil,
and then now that was conceptualized as
a transcendent spirit.
Right?
So that's the spirit of Satan who's the
WHO's the adversary of the hero,
the adversary of the hero,
and that's why there's an association
between the snake in the garden.
And this is great series of mythologies
about the existence of evil itself.
It's a consequence of our continued
capacity to abstract.
We started using the Predator detection
system to detect snakes and maybe no
predatory cats and maybe birds of prey
and all that,
but that didn't solve the bloody problem
because just because you hid from the
predatory bird today didn't mean the
bloody thing wasn't going to be back
tomorrow and tomorrow starts to matter
as you get smarter,
and then once you're on that pathway and
you starting to think about abstractly
about the Predator,
the nature of what constitutes the
Predator starts to become because you're
trying to solve that across all
situations similar,
it starts to become very much more
abstract and it ends up being something
like a personality,
like an eternal personality and in the
internal personality that has its effect
on everyone all the time.
So and it's so.
It's so interesting to see those ideas
because they basically evolved.
People did not understand those ideas as
they produced them.
Right?
It was all put forward in a massive
mythological context and in a rich story
context,
and the stories were as conscious as the
information got.
It was never articulated past the level
of story.
So remarkable.
Absolutely remarkable.
Okay,
so let's take a break for 15 minutes.
Now we're going to make things
complicated.
So this I showed you this map before and
I wanted to.
I produced this map because I,
I was trying to understand the
fundamental substructure of the
mythological world.
I think that's the right way of thinking
about it and I'm not claiming that this
is the only way it can be represented
because I know full well that it can be
represented other ways,
but it's a pretty good schema.
And so the idea it maps onto.
Yeah,
it maps onto this idea,
so you can imagine that when you're here
you're unexplored territory.
Okay,
so explored territory.
You can.
The explored territory in an archaic way
is the fires at the center,
the campfire and the tribal boundary
surrounds that space and that's safe
space.
Okay,
so it's a place in nature obviously
within which there's a pyramid and
there's a fire at the center of the
pyramid,
and the pyramid is the dominance
hierarchy,
the social dominance hierarchy,
and that's where people live.
That's the world.
And so you could say,
well that's circumscribes space where
you understand.
See,
it's the explored territory,
not only because you understand the
natural world that prevails there and
the cumulative effort of all of your
compatriots keeps all the terrible
animals at bay so it's actually safe
from a natural perspective and you
understand it,
so it's explored when you're there,
you're safe and good things happen to
you mostly and then not a but a,
but it isn't just the natural space
construed as the environment.
It's the natural space construed of the
relationship between you and all the
other primates that inhabit that space,
which is also.
It's so society obviously,
but it's also part of nature and so that
explored territory is your understanding
of the natural world and the social
world,
but more importantly the concordance of
your understanding with what's happening
in that space.
So like take this place,
for example,
right now,
every one of you has expectations about
what's going to happen in this classroom
and you bring those and their desires
actually did not merely expectations
because it's goal directed and you bring
those with you into the classroom and as
long as what's happening is in
concordance with those desires,
then you're safe and calm and maybe at
least mildly interested,
which would be the point,
right?
So it's explored territory because what
you understand matches what's happening
and that's a place and it's a place that
you strive to be and you strive to
maintain and maybe you even strive to
expand,
which which is a slightly different
thing,
but you certainly strive to maintain it.
That's this,
that's one place.
Then there's another place which is
where you end up with that doesn't work,
and you can think about that as well.
You know in the lion king,
for example,
when when Mufasa Mufasa brings Simba up
to the top of pride rock just when the
sun is either rising or setting,
and so they're on top of the rock and
the top of the rock is lit and they're
sitting up the top in the light and
Mufasa tells Simba that his territory is
everything that the light touches and
everything that the light touches is
everything that you've understood.
It's everything that your capacity for
illumination and enlightenment has
turned into a habitable space,
and so you're the king of that domain,
right?
Especially in so far as you're guided by
the light.
That's what that little scene meant and
move fasa tells Simba not to go out
beyond where the light has touched into
the dark territories and that's where
the elephant graveyard is in that story.
Right?
And move our Simba and Nala go out there
because of course,
as soon as you tell a human being not to
do something,
those little lions being human beings
after all,
they immediately run off and do it,
and that's an echo of the story.
Say in in,
in Genesis,
where God tells Adam and eve not to eat
the apple and this the first thing they
immediately do because if you want
someone not to do something,
you first specify what it is that they
shouldn't do and then give them some
sort of incomprehensible reason for why
they shouldn't do it,
and they'll just do it instantly because
that's what we're like,
right?
That's the way the Catholics are
convinced that people suffer from
original sin and it's a very intelligent
way of looking at things.
Although it also has its problems.
So anyways,
there's the.
There's the known territory and then
outside of that there's unknown
territory and those are the most
fundamental elements of existence.
There's the place you are when you know
what's going on and there's the place
you are when you don't know what's going
on and that can be mapped onto
geographic territory.
If you go on beyond the borders of your
society,
then you're in unknown territory,
but it can also be mapped conceptually
so that,
for example,
we're all sitting in this room and
someone leaps in with a weapon.
It's like this was known territory a
second ago and now it's not known
territory at all,
even though you'd say,
well,
many things have remained the same.
It's like,
yeah,
but all the relevant things have
suddenly changed.
Right,
and so part of the way of
conceptualizing that is that you can,
you can manifest a geographic
transformation by moving from genuine
geographic,
explored territory into genuine
unexplored territory,
but you can do that in time as well
because we exist in time as well as
space and so a space that's stable and
unchanging can be transformed into
something completely other than it is by
the movement forward of time so well.
So why am I telling you that?
It's because we've mapped the idea of
the difference in space between the
known and the unknown to the difference
in time between a place that works now
at a place that no longer works,
even though it's the same place.
It's the same thing.
It's just extended across time.
All right,
and so that's order versus chaos and
that's the chaos that can manifest
itself within the order.
The thing that's represented in the Yin
and Yang symbol,
right,
because you see the Black Paisley with
the white and the White Paisley with the
black.in
that order can turn into chaos at a
moment's notice and in the same way
chaos can turn to order in a moments
notice at a moment's notice,
and so we're trying to map the geography
onto the,
onto the APP,
onto something that's more abstract and
comprehensive and and and we do that
using conceptual schemes that we evolved
over vast spans of time and have just
moved up one level of obstruction,
known territory or what's exploring
unknown territory or what's not
explored.
The trans transformation or the
disillusion of one into the other,
and then the reconstitution of that.
That's when an election does,
right?
It's like,
okay,
we have our leader who's the person at
the top of the dominance hierarchy and
defines the nature of this particular
structure.
There's an election.
It's regulated chaos.
No one knows what's going to happen.
It's the death of the old king.
Bang.
We go into a chaotic state.
Everyone argues for awhile and then out
of that argument they produce a
consensus and Poof,
we're in a new state,
right?
That's the Metta story,
Order,
chaos order,
but it's partial order,
chaos,
reconstituted,
and revivified order.
That's the thing is that this order is
better than that order,
so there's progress and that's partly
why I think the idea of moral relativism
is wrong.
There's progress in moral order and it
was defined property by piaget.
The new moral order does everything.
The other boral,
the old moral order did and some
additional things.
That's what constitutes progress.
Now here's a,
here's a strange idea and we'll talk
about this more as we progress through
the class.
What's the ultimate in order?
Well,
it's not there,
so obviously because it can collapse and
it's not this because it can collapse
and so then you think,
well,
there's no ultimate order even though
there's progression,
but then you have to move it up.
One level of abstraction.
What's the ultimate order doing this
willingness to do that?
That's the ultimate order,
right?
It's order at a different level of
analysis and you can see that's what's
represented in that idea.
That's what that idea means.
That's the phoenix.
The Phoenix is something that lives ages
and then allows itself to be consumed by
fire and then reemerge us and they
pulled.
Phoenix gets old and Burns and the new
phoenix reemergence,
and so the real phoenix is the thing
that's constant across those
transformations.
That's the union self.
That's what he meant.
The self is the element of the psyche
that remains intact across
transformations.
Yeah.
It's a bloody amazing idea.
That's for sure,
and you can think about that.
That's why you haven't claimed,
for example,
in ion primarily that Christ was a
symbol of the self that was his
consequence of decades of meditation on
the structure of Christianity because
it's the dying and resurrecting part of
the psyche that remains constant across
the transformation.
So the ultimate order isn't to identify
with this.
That's your current state of being and
it isn't identified with that because,
well,
you can't by definition and it isn't
even to identify with that.
It's to let these things go as they need
to go.
That's a sacrifice and to allow this
continual process of transformation to
occur,
and part of that is the admission that
you're wrong,
and so partly what you're doing is at
micro levels and macro levels where are
you not what you could be and when you
realize that it'll take you apart a
little bit and burn you down to your
core a little bit and then allow you to
regenerate.
And if you do that continually,
the everything that you don't need burns
away.
Right?
And that's what this means.
You remember in Harry Potter,
you may remember that Harry goes down,
so in the second volume and in the
second movie,
Harry's at Harvard,
so it's the school where you learn how
to be magic because that's what you
really are,
and there's something that threatens the
school.
Well,
part of what threatens the school.
Evil,
right?
Voldemort.
That's one thing,
but at the same time,
it's also the snake that lurks
underneath.
It's the basilisk that threatens the
school,
and so the Basilisk is the dragon,
and when the bassline looks at you,
then you're paralyzed because you're a
prey animal and if a Predator captures
you in its gaze,
you freeze,
and the reason you freeze is because
your body reacts to the Predator as
something that should turn you to stone.
Sorry about that.
So what do you do about the basilisk?
Well,
one thing you do is you run and hide,
but the other thing you do is go
confronted and it slayer and that's what
Harry Potter does now.
And what's interesting about him is he's
also touched by evil,
right?
And that means that he's an embodiment
of what you would regard as someone
who's integrated the shadow and without
that capacity isn't able to communicate,
say with snakes.
And that's not so good because since
there are snakes,
it's not such a bad idea to know how to
communicate with them and he goes down
into the underground,
right into the chaotic domain that's
underneath the school in order to find
the snake.
And it's layer.
Now,
if I remember correctly,
you can you tell me if I'm wrong,
it doesn't really go down through a
bathroom through a toilet.
Right?
Well,
so that's an indication of the union
dictum that where are you,
what you most what you need most is to
be found where you least want to look.
I had a client once who actually had a
dream like that.
He dreamt that he had to go into the
underground world through an outhouse.
Right.
Was very,
very interesting and it was an
elaboration of precisely this theme.
It's what you've thrown away as of
little value to you and maybe what you
hate and hold in contempt and fear is
exactly what you have to face if you
want to go down to the place where the
transformations occur.
So what happens in Harry Potter,
while this Bass licks his wandering
around paralyzing everyone who isn't
able to communicate with snakes and he
doesn't fight the bast list precisely.
He goes down into its layers,
the underground world,
and that what what down there is that
snake has got a generic Vra,
right?
His girlfriend,
that's her name,
right?
It's a,
it's a,
it's a variant of Virginia that's a
variant of virgin and the snake always
has a virgin.
That's one of its characteristics,
right?
Like gold.
He goes down there to rescue her.
What happens to him?
He gets bit and he's going to die.
So what happens?
The Phoenix comes along and cries tears
into his wounds and charism,
and that's
so the idea is that what saves you in
the encounter with the snake is your
capacity to let things go and die and
come back to life.
Right.
It's so interesting a that,
that,
that story is told in that way,
in that series of volumes because the,
the,
the plot structure is perfect in a
mythological sense.
It's exactly right.
And the Phoenix APP actually happens to
be the pat of the main wizard,
which is also perfect.
It's exactly right.
So you know,
what's his name now?
Who?
Dumbledore.
Yeah.
He's basically,
for all intents and purposes,
God the father and his pat,
his,
his close ally is the thing that can die
and that transforms.
Well.
You can see the echoes of Christian
thought in that,
but that isn't exactly right.
It's the Christian thought and the
mythological substructure upon which the
Harry Potter volume is based,
are drawing from the same underlying
pool of ideas and symbols and they're
universally accessible and you can tell
that because if they weren't,
that book wouldn't have sold how many
million copies,
how many million copies did itself and
the movies.
It's unbelievably overwhelmingly
powerful.
She got kids to read 600 page books,
like multiple volumes lining up for
them.
You got to ask yourself why silly
stories about magical orphans.
It's like,
well,
maybe not.
Maybe people aren't so stupid and
certainly if they happen to be reading
relatively complex books,
attributing that to stupidity seems to
be rather counterproductive.
Alright,
so that's the chaotic domain.
Now we got to think about the chaotic
domain for a minute.
The chaotic domain is where you don't
know what's going to happen and anything
could happen.
Positive or negative,
anything can happen,
and so you can think about the chaotic
domain as the birthplace of order.
It's the place from which order emerges.
Well,
it's,
it can in some sense.
You remember what happens in Pinocchio,
so Pinocchio goes down into the depths
and the and then into the whale to
rescue his father.
He goes to the most frightening place
possible.
He tests himself against it and he
rescues his father and he brings him up
to the surface,
but the consequence of that is that he
dies,
but what dies is the stupid puppet,
and so the question is,
well,
to the degree that you're a stupid
puppet,
are you willing to let that die?
And the answer to that is it depends on
the degree to which you're actually a
stupid puppet because the more that's
true,
the more of you has to die and it's not
something trivial.
That's why these myths insist upon the
horror of the thing that lurks,
so to speak is that that death might be
enough to actually kill you if you're
not properly prepared for it.
And that's what happens to people who
are extraordinarily traumatized,
for example.
It's like huge parts of them are killed
and,
and they often don't recover.
So it's no joke.
Well,
and then of course this is often acted
out in the real world too,
if you know this can happen on a
psychological basis and so your own
psychological experiences can be enough
to radically disrupt and hurt you,
but it can be worked out in the real
world too because if you're wandering
around naively with your eyes closed and
you run into someone who's really
psychopathic,
they'll take you apart and you'll have
no defense against it whatsoever because
you're too blinded,
naive,
and if you encounter someone like that
and they leave you in the ashes,
which they might,
it certainly possible that you'll never
recover from it.
You just will not be able to handle the
aftermath,
but also you won't be able to handle the
fact that something like that could
actually happen,
and that's really the nature of of
trauma.
You cannot believe that that could
actually happen and that's an encounter.
It's almost always,
and this has been the case,
certainly be my clinical experience.
What traumatizes people is malevolence.
It's not tragedy,
although tragedy can traumatize people
if it's severe enough,
but generally no people can withstand
tragedy.
They are done in by real malevolence and
so sometimes it's the realization of
their own malevolence that does the men,
but when that isn't the case,
they encounter someone who's out there
in the world who's actually operating to
hurt them and so and if the person is
psychopathic enough and this is actually
goes beyond pure psychopathy because at
least the psychopath has the sense to be
self interested.
You can go far farther than that where
you're perfectly willing to hurt
yourself as long as you hurt the other
person at the same time and that's where
you go.
When you're doing something like
conjuring up the idea that you might
shoot up a school because those people
always killed themselves at the end and
you might think,
well,
why don't they just save everyone a lot
of trouble and killed themselves at the
beginning?
Well,
that wouldn't exactly be the point.
What they what they want to say.
His life means nothing to me.
Nothing,
but I'm perfectly willing to make as
many people as I possibly can suffer
before I demonstrate that.
And so that's a step past psychopathy,
and if you encounter that in someone,
it's or in yourself,
that's going to be a deeply unsettling
experience.
An idea behind many of these stories is
that you cannot figure out what to do
about that before you haven't
encountered like that.
And if you think about that properly,
that's,
that's as horrifying and experience as
you could imagine,
right?
It's precisely that.
It's as horrifying and experience as you
could imagine.
So all right,
so back this chaos.
This is the birthplace of things.
That's why often it's represented as
feminine because feminine things are the
of things.
Now again,
you know,
people are stuck with the necessity of
interpreting their experience through
the biological platform of
interpretation that they evolved.
And so we could say,
well,
we,
we recognize feminine,
we recognize masculine,
we recognize parent,
we recognize child,
and that's,
that's ancient,
right?
That's as ancient as mammals.
And so those are fundamental social
cognitive categories.
And we had to exploit those categories
to represent the world.
Beyond that,
when we started to be able to represent
the world beyond that,
you as a,
just as a primate,
like a chimpanzee or a tree dwelling
primary to complex primate,
almost all of their categories are
social,
cognitive,
right?
Why?
Because they live in complex social
environments and there's a relationship
between the size of the social
environment that a primate inhabits and
it's brain size.
The bigger the brain,
the larger the environment,
and you could think there's a loop
there,
right?
If your brain's too small,
you can't handle the larger environment,
so the environment grows and it selects
for people,
for creatures that are complex enough to
compute the environment,
and then that gives us selective
advantage to creatures that are acute it
or are sharp enough to compute the
environment and so there's more of them
and it loops and the brain grows and and
it's not the only thing driving the
evolution of the brain among primates,
but it's.
It's a primary source.
So we have those categories to begin
with and then we have to view the world
as it manifests itself outside those
primary categories.
Through the lens of those categories,
and so what happens is we use the
symbolism of of sex differentiation and
the symbolism of parent child
relationships to to begin to account for
the manner in which the world manifests
itself masculine.
Why?
Well,
that's the patriarchy,
chaos,
feminine.
Why?
Well,
partly it's conceived of in opposition
to the patriarchy,
but more importantly,
it's the thing from which order rises,
so it's perfectly reasonable to consider
it feminine and then order again,
and then the question is,
well,
you have order,
father,
chaos,
mother,
and then you have this,
this transformational process.
Well,
that's the mythological hero and those
are the three fundamental characters of
mythology,
individual culture,
nature,
right?
It's the universal world,
and then that's differentiated.
Further positive individual,
negative,
individual heroin,
adversary,
tyrant and wise king.
The destructive element of nature and
the creative element of nature and and
those are perfectly reasonable
categories.
They,
they do a lovely job of actually
representing how the world does manifest
itself to us in the domains that are
permanent.
There's always a conscious observer
who's ambivalent about the nature of the
world.
There's always a social structure that's
half tyrannical and half order producing
and there's always the nature that gives
rise to everything and that destroys it.
At the same time always it's permanent
and so that's another reason it's so
interesting.
That's another reason why the
mythological representations or hyper
real because they think what makes
something real.
Let's say protons are real.
Why?
Because at one level of analysis,
every single thing is made out of
protons,
so you can use it as an explanatory
tool.
The concept,
you can use it as an explanatory tool
for every possible situation and it's
true across all possible spans of time.
Although protons do decay,
but it takes billions and billions of
years,
so real means works now.
It works forever,
applies now and applies everywhere.
Well,
that's exactly what this map means.
It's that there's always an observer.
There's always a framework of
interpretation and there's always that
which is being observed.
There's always the the individual,
there's always the social environment,
the dominance hierarchy,
and there's always the nature that
exists outside of that.
There's always the knower,
the known and the unknown always.
So then the question is,
well,
how do those things interrelate while
you differentiate them into their
positive and negative elements because
there's always the positive and negative
element and then you tell stories about
how the different categories interact
and that's what the stories do and the
more mythological the story,
the more that underlying Schema is self
evident in the,
in the,
in the plot and you especially see that
I think in stories for children and
maybe that's because children can't
understand stories unless they're
archetipal like blatantly archetipal and
that would make sense,
right?
Because the stories have to appeal to
the instinctive knowledge of the child
or the child wouldn't be able to
comprehend them.
And so I saw this quite dramatically
with my own kids watching them watch
Disney movies.
For example.
My Son was absolutely obsessed with
Pinocchio and particularly obsessed with
the scene where Pinocchio and and his
father are escaping from the whale and
the whale turns into this sort of smoke
belching locomotive thing that's chasing
them through the water.
He would rewind that and watch it and
rewind it and watch it and rewind it and
watch it like over and over and over.
You think what the hell's that kid up
to?
Well,
you know,
it took us what,
six hours to do a brief run through
through Pinocchio.
Still by still.
There's a lot of information in that
movie.
A tremendous amount of information and
then with the kids trying to do is to
incorporate it to,
to understand it,
to embody it and that's all happening in
some sense.
I would say unconsciously it's like it's
unconscious in that he couldn't
articulate what he was doing and neither
could anyone else,
but that doesn't mean he wasn't doing
something.
He was definitely something.
He was doing the same thing that enabled
my nephew to put on the night suit when
he did that little night hat and the
sword and figure out how to go after the
great dragon of chaos.
And so I wanted to tell you a little bit
more about this idea of chaos.
So here's the Schema of have the
architectural son and we'll get to why
it's masculine and not feminine,
and that's also taken me a long time to
crack because the women in this class
have always asked me,
well,
the hero and mythological stories is
male.
Where does that leave women?
And I never knew what to say about that
exactly.
You can look at sleeping beauty,
for example,
that that that story and sleeping beauty
is raised rescued by a prince,
and you can think of that prince at two
levels of analysis simultaneously.
You can think about it as an actual mail
who plays that role,
but you can also think about it as the
exploratory and exploratory,
assertive and courageous part of the
feminine psyche that's necessary to
bring unconsciousness up into
consciousness and the story works
perfectly across both those levels of
analysis.
So,
so and that is.
That is the classic way I would say,
of,
of explaining this particular mode of
representation,
but it came to my attention.
This was so interesting.
This is.
This is what triggered this for me.
Finally,
I was reading this book called a billion
wicked thoughts that was written by a
bunch of engineers at Google and they
were looking at billions of search,
billions of google searches and you
know,
there's no shortage of pornography on
the Internet and it and there's much
less by proportion than there was when
the Internet was first invented and it's
so interesting because it actually
turned out that one of the things that
drove the development of the Internet
and the technology was the proclivity of
young men to search out sexually
provocative images.
That was what was at the forefront of
the development of the nets.
Extraordinarily interesting.
They were motivated to.
They were motivated to use it for that
purpose and that provided the platform
from which it emerged.
Amazing.
Anyways,
the Google engineers looked at
pornographic search processes and then
segregated male searches from female
searches and what they found was that
the mail search scout images,
price surprise,
no one,
no one considers that,
you know,
particularly interesting.
But the female searched out literary
representations of pornography.
It was written.
And so I can give you an example of
that.
If you know about harlequin romances,
does everybody still know about those?
Anybody not know about those?
Okay,
well there are mass market romances and
have a very stereotypical type and
they're.
The original ones were pretty harmless
in terms of no violence and no real
sexual contact con content,
but that was 40 years ago and they've
differentiated tremendously and now
there's hardcore harlequin romances and
with,
with particularly garish covers and then
there's the old more tame basic sexless
and aggression list.
Romance is where everything is implied
and not explicit,
but the explicit ones exist.
So they did a plot analysis of the
typical pornographic female fantasy.
Well,
and it was so.
It's so comical because engineers did
this.
Social scientists would never do this
because they'd be probably too concerned
about the ethics of it or some damn
thing,
but engineers,
you know,
they'll just plow ahead with no concern
whatsoever for such things and they
actually discover things that way.
And so they,
they discovered the basic plot of the
female pornographic literary product and
they identified.
So basically what happened was that a
innocent well meaning an attractive
young woman encounters a male who's a
bit of a monster and the monster is five
types of classic male monster for all
your males who want to know this is what
you can become a vampire.
That's a good one.
We're a wolf,
billionaire.
Pirate and surgeon.
Okay.
So that's very interesting because.
Well first of all there's a dominance
thing.
There's a.
Now you're actually blushing.
You know,
you're actually blushing about that.
That's very,
very funny.
So sorry to point it out,
but it's so comical,
you know.
Yeah,
I know.
It's so funny.
I was reading this,
I was reading this.
It was just cracking me up.
I thought,
oh my God,
really?
Pirate Vampire,
all of that explains it.
What about all these damn vampire shows,
right there are so popular online.
They're so popular on Netflix.
Oh yes.
And then there's the werewolf.
There's nothing sexier than a werewolf
apparently,
but I mean,
so there's predatory dope.
There's predatory dominance that's
implicit in that,
right?
With a billionaire,
it's more abstract,
but clearly that's an indication of very
high success in the male dominance
hierarchy,
so but there's this desire for
aggression that's in that are real
aggression,
right,
and it's not surprising to me,
to me at all,
it makes perfect sense,
but what about the basic plot is that
the woman encounters this mysterious and
aggressive male and teams.
That's the female hero myth as far as I
can tell,
it's beauty and the beast and so it's
because,
well,
there's no fun in taming someone who's
already tame and what makes you think
you really want someone who's many
anyways.
There's no interest in that.
Plus when,
when,
when chaos manifests itself,
what makes you think that someone team
is going to be good for anything and
it's a real question and so that
aggression is absolutely vital.
It's absolutely necessary,
but because it's incredibly dangerous,
which of course it is,
it has to be civilized and so what
happens is that the archetypal female in
these pornographic romances,
seduces and tames,
aggressive male,
and that's her encounter with chaos.
Now it's more,
it's more,
of course females,
they're more complicated and that's
exactly how it is and it's no wonder
because there their lives are more
complicated,
but okay,
so back to this,
so.
So this map isn't predicated on the
beauty and beast story and I don't know
what to do about that at the moment,
but whatever.
We're going to go with this map for the
time being because it's been the
dominant one.
You have the archetypical son whose
hero,
an adversary that's cane versus able,
for example,
a table versus cane hero versus
adversary and then that that that Dyad,
that hostile brothers,
that's the Motif,
mythological motif that that lays out.
It's a very common mythological motif
that's nested inside the social order of
order versus tyranny and that's nested
inside the destruction and creation of
nature.
And then all of that is nested inside
the dragon of chaos.
And so it's interesting because you say
this is you have the the entity that
knows and that's the hero,
and then you have the structure within
which that entity is operating and then
you have the unknown.
It's the sun,
it's the father.
It's the mother,
the mother stands for chaos,
but outside of that there's this
additional chaos that's paradoxical and
you might say,
well,
why do you need to have two kinds of
chaos?
And that's where things get ridiculously
complicated.
The little or chaos is what's defined in
relationship to what you already know,
so it's manageable in some sense.
It's that which combined with what you
already know can bring something forth
that there's a sexual metaphor in that
you take what you know.
You take something you don't know,
you put them together.
This isn't enough to overwhelm this and
this isn't enough to suppress this.
The two come together in a creative
union and something new is born from it,
so that's the Holy Father,
the holy mother bang and the hero that
emerges out of that.
Okay,
but then there's the chaos that so
overwhelming that it just demolishes
everything and it's the ultimate source
of what's known and what's unknown in
relationship to what's known and the
knower itself,
and that's symbolized by this dragon of
chaos,
and I'm going to show you another way of
thinking about it.
It's the most primordial of symbols.
Here's the PSG and idea.
Child occupies a circumscribed domain of
knowledge.
The child applies that domain of
knowledge to the world.
Generally that works.
Sometimes it doesn't.
Something unexpected happens,
okay,
and that that unexpected thing can be
different.
Cataclysmic significance.
Let's say if it's too overwhelming,
the child will just cry and then the
parent comes in and fixes up the
anomalous thing,
but the child's and playing,
you know,
pushes his food off the table or pushes
the spoon off the table and watches it
fall and is playing and he's playing at
the edge of order and chaos trying to
expand his knowledge domains at the rate
that is most palatable to him.
We'll say,
so what's happening precisely?
Well,
you can say that the child is in a
specific place and is doing a specific
thing with the specific outcome or you
can generalize from that and you can
say,
well,
the child is occupying a structured is
occupying a structure,
a cognitive structure,
and there's that which is outside the
cognitive structure and then you might
say,
well how do you conceptualize that?
Which is outside the cognitive structure
and now answer to that is you can't
because it's outside the cognitive
structure,
but it still exists and so here's a way
of conceptualizing it.
What's outside?
The cognitive structure is latent
information.
It's a domain of latent information and
information means in formation,
right?
And so what you're trying to do when you
go beyond your knowledge structure is to
look for new regularities in the
environment that you can map and
incorporate them into your,
into your structure,
but that that domain of and information,
that's chaos itself and that's what's
symbolized by the dragon of chaos.
That's why its Predator,
multidimensional Predator plus thing
that holds treasure at the same time
because in order for us to guard
ourselves,
here's a way of thinking about it.
In order for us to guard ourselves
properly against the internal eternal
existence of the absolute unknown,
we had to conceptualize it first.
I can say absolute unknown.
It's like,
well,
car.
Do you think that's such a strange
category?
It's the category of all things that
have not yet been categorized.
It's like zero.
It's like the antithesis of zero.
It took people a long time to come up
with the idea of zero.
It's such,
it's the category that contains nothing.
Well,
what do you need a category like that
for well to do mathematics?
As it turns out,
this category is the category of all
things that have not yet been mastered
and your job is to be a master of the
category of all things that have not yet
been mastered and you're not going to do
that until you can conceptualize it.
You conceptualize it with the gold
hoarding,
Metta Predator,
because that's your opponent and your
job is not to.
Your job is to know how to confront that
continually and to extract out from it
what it holds is value and that's the
permanent solution to the problem
because it's never going to go away,
right?
It's an eternal thing.
All you can do is master it the same way
that a surfer masters await you,
master it in the process of mastering
it.
There is no solution to the problem
except the solution of continual
mastery,
and so that's what you are.
You're shaped transforming wizard.
That's doing its best to keep up with
the continual transformation of that
which you do not yet understand,
and I think there's absolutely no
difference between that by the way,
and this thing that women chase in their
pornographic fantasies.
It's the same thing.
It's the same thing,
the word wall,
so good example of that,
and the vampire,
right?
There's,
there's this capacity for what's normal
to transform into something that's
extraordinarily aggressive and to
manifest mastery as a consequence of
that.
So it's the transforming spirit and it
can transform itself and it without
bound and certainly in directions that
aren't socially acceptable.
Let's say there's A.
There's a,
there's a line you want to be able to
push and that's again why in in the
Harry Potter stories,
Harry,
first of all is touched by evil and
second is always breaking rules
constantly,
right?
And he's the most favored.
So interesting because he's the most
favored of Dumbledore,
precisely because he knows when to break
rules.
And so it's so interesting because
double door,
of course,
is the spirit of,
let's call it the patriarchy for all
intents and purposes,
and his favorite is that child that
refer refuses to abide by the rules of
the patriarchy,
but only under the proper circumstances,
right?
You don't sacrifice the old rule unless
you have a reason for doing so.
The thing you're doing has to be better
than the thing that you would be
compelled to do by the old rule.
And then you have to dare to do it.
And you'd say,
well,
you're not going to do that unless
you're already touched to some degree by
the spirit of the snake.
And that's exactly right.
See,
okay,
here's another way of thinking about it.
The winged reptile is a thing of the
earth and a thing of the sky.
So you could think about it as a thing
of matter and to thing of spirit.
Okay?
So then the question is,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
It's a symbol of the union of spirit and
matter.
Okay,
so what's matter?
Well,
the world,
but it isn't just the world.
It's also what matters.
And what spirit?
Well,
it's the thing that flies free of the
material world that's above the ground,
that's,
that's in the theoretical space that's
up in heaven,
but it's also whatever it is in us,
that psyche or spirit,
okay,
so then you might say,
well,
what's the origin of that
chaos?
And we can actually,
I don't want to put that out as a
metaphysical proposition.
I want to put it out as an extension of
what we've been saying.
So the child,
the child bootstraps itself up from
nothing roughly speaking right through
its developmental process is the merges,
has a fully fledged nervous system and
it produces cognitive structures within
which it exists and views the world.
But there's something outside of the
cognitive structures and that's this
latent information will say,
well then we could say that latent
information is properly conceptualized
as matter and spirit.
Why?
Because when you investigate it,
when you interact with it,
you parse it into the world and into
you.
That's what it means to be informed by
your contact with the unknown.
It informs you.
It makes you more than you are,
and so it's like your extra.
That's the resource you're extracting
from the absolute unknown.
It's the information that allows you to
reconstitute your being.
At the same time you differentiate your
knowledge of the world,
so matter emerges from the latent
information and what matters and you
emerge from the latent information in
this,
this dialogical process that involves
your continual exploration.
You build yourself and you build the
world,
and so the dragon of chaos,
the wing dragon of chaos that guards the
gold is the latest information that when
you explore,
enables you to build yourself and to
differentiate the world.
I'll tell you a story,
Dan.
This.
This is one of the great stories of
mankind and it's not.
This isn't the only variant of this
story.
There's many variants of it,
but,
but this variant is useful for,
for our purposes.
That's a story I stumbled across a long
time ago.
I'm going to tell you the second story
first because I don't have the energy to
tell you the first story.
So this is a story that the ancient
Egyptians predicated their society on.
And to understand this story,
the first thing you have to know is what
the characters were in these characters
were gods.
There's four of them.
Although the Egyptians had far more than
four gods.
You might think of these as the central
Gods and you might think what is the
central God?
And then you might think,
well,
imagine that the gods compete for
dominance across time in people's
imaginations and some gods when they
occupied the primary position of
dominance in the hierarchy,
in the dominance hierarchy of gods.
And those are ideals and ideals compete
across time for dominance and their
embodied.
And so when diverse tribal people come
together,
they throw all their gods into the ring
and they fight across time and something
emerges as a victor.
And that's the emergence of monotheism
out of polytheism.
And it parallels the development of a
unified morality in within each of us as
we develop across time and the the god
that emerges as dominant across time
bears a substantial,
represent a substantial
resemblance.
Imagine you have a set of gods in this
locale that are competing across time
and something emerges as dominant,
and then over here you have another set
of gods that compete across time,
dominance and something emerges.
You'll see major commonalities across
the two things that emerge and the
reason for that is because the emergent,
the process of emergence that gives rise
to both of them is similar in both
situations,
and that's part of what accounts for the
cross cultural similarity of high order
religious ideas.
All right.
Anyways,
you need to know the characters.
Oh,
Cyrus Cyrus is the old king.
He's Dumbledore.
For all intents and purposes,
he's the old king.
He's the.
He's the spirit that established the
Egyptian state.
When he was young,
he was a great hero,
but now he's old and he's willing.
He's archaic and he's willfully blind.
That's Cyrus.
He has a brother Seth.
Seth is set and set is Satan because the
word Satan comes from the word Seth and
set via the Coptic Christians.
So,
so.
So he's a precursor to the western idea
of Satan.
You have isis.
Isis is queen of the underworld,
and Isis was the goddess of a religious
structure that prevailed across
thousands and thousands of years.
Isis and you have horace.
Horace is a Falcon,
and the Egyptian,
I.
everyone's knows that I write with the
open pupil.
That's horace.
And Horace is a falcon because falcons
can see way better.
They can see better than us.
They can see better than anything else
except for perhaps eagles.
And they fly above everything.
Zazu in lion king is horace,
right?
And [inaudible] Fossa is Cyrus and scar
is seth.
And there's no specific representation
of Isis,
but the closest there is in that story
is probably the queen of the hyenas.
That's played by a,
the actress.
Um Hm.
Yes.
Whoopi Goldberg.
That's right.
Because she.
They inhabit.
She's like the queen of the underworld,
right?
She's the queen of the hyenas that live
out in among the death.
But okay.
Anyways,
Seth Osiris,
seth,
Isis,
and horace.
Here's how the story goes.
Well,
cirrus is a great cake.
He established the Egyptian state.
You could think about him as the
embodiment of the,
of Egyptian custom and tradition.
You can think about a as the thing that
the pyramid represents.
All right,
but he was great when he was young,
but he's not young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind,
and what that means is that he doesn't
see what he could see.
He refuses to see what he could see.
Why is,
oh,
cirrus old and willfully blind because
that's what culture is.
It's a paternal spirit that's old and
willfully blind and it's always that
way,
always that way,
and the reason for that is because it's
a construction of the dad.
The Dad aren't alive,
they can't,
so they're out of date.
They can't update themselves anymore and
you inhabit their corpse and that's
actually what happens in an earlier
story that I'll tell you next week,
that early Mesopotamian gods inhabited
the corpse of their father,
roughly speaking anyway.
So,
oh,
Cyrus was great and when he was young,
but he wasn't young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind.
He won't look where he knows he should
look.
He doesn't have the energy or maybe he
doesn't have the spirit.
His brother Seth is not a good guy and
no cyrus knows it,
but he underestimates his malevolence
and power,
and so seth wants to rule the kingdom.
So what does that mean?
It's easy.
Every stable society is,
is threatened by willful blindness and
malevolence always.
Every bureaucracy has that proclivity to
stagnate and to become blind.
That's why corporations die all the
time.
That's why a fortune 500 company only
last 30 years.
It's why we have to have elections.
It's to stop the Dad from staying in
control for too long.
Seth Cyrus turns a blind eye to seth.
Seth is happy about that same thing
happens in the lion king,
roughly speaking.
Seth one day waits for a cyrus to make a
mistake and to be weak,
and he attacks him and he chops it up
into pieces and he distributed to the
pieces across the entire Egyptian state.
In fact,
the Egyptians regarded their provinces
as pieces of,
oh,
Cyrus's body.
Okay,
so now you can kill or cyrus because
he's a god.
And why is he god a God?
Because he represents the spirit of
structure and there's always structure.
It can't be destroyed.
It always reconstitutes itself.
It can be hurt and broken into pieces,
which is exactly what happens to a
cyrus.
Things fall apart.
Why?
Because they get old and because
malevolence undermines them.
That's what the Egyptians were trying to
sort out.
Okay,
so seth distributes is.
Oh,
cyrus all over Egypt.
So he can't get himself back together.
Right?
Things fall apart and they can't be
brought back together.
But the spirit of Vocera still lives in
the pieces.
So what happens?
Orders demolished.
What would you expect?
Chaos emerges.
That's isis.
Isis is queen of the underworld.
She's Cyrus's wife,
order and chaos.
Just like the Yin and the Yang order
collapses.
Up comes the queen of the underworld.
She's looking for order.
Chaos cries out for order.
She goes all around Egypt trying to put
our.
So Cyrus back together.
It's a state of chaos.
She finds this fellas.
She makes herself pregnant with it.
And what does that mean?
Well,
it means it's like it's like Japan in
the belly of the whale.
That thing has the potential to reemerge
this.
The thing that collapses into its
pieces,
it's still alive.
It can unite with the chaos and produce
something new.
That's the story of the disillusion of
structure into chaos and then it's
reverification.
Isis makes herself pregnant.
She goes back down to the underworld.
She gives birth to horace.
Horace is the Egyptian I show.
He's the son of the great father and the
great mother.
He's a.
he's a mess.
Cyanic figure,
and in fact,
much of the mythology that described
horace was extracted without much
modification and then attributed to
Christ.
Very much memory and you can read about
the parallels.
You read about it online if you want.
There's any number of parallels and of
course there is a mythology that the
Jews came out of Egypt and of course the
Christians emerged from the juice and so
there was a tremendous influence of
Egyptian thinking on the development of
these later ideas and you see pictures
of Isis with horace on her lap that are
virtually identical in content and form
to the later pictures of Mary with the
infant Christ.
But that's the holy mother of God in the
hero.
It's not a Christian motif,
it's far deeper than a Christian motif.
It's a human motif,
so isis,
queen of the underworld gives birth to
horace,
and horace grows up outside the kingdom.
Why in underworld?
Because that's what human beings do.
You're alienated from your culture
always why?
It's old and dead and corrupt,
and so that leaves you growing up in
chaos.
What would you call alienated from your
fundamental culture?
That's the story of adolescence.
Horace grows up.
He can see that's what differentiates
them from,
oh,
Cyrus,
that's why he's a falcon.
He goes and has a fight with seth,
and now the difference between Osiris
and Horus is that horse does not
underestimate seth.
He knows exactly what he's up against.
He goes and has a terrible battle with
him trying to get his kingdom back.
Something else that's echoed in the lion
king story and well horus and or seth or
fighting seth terrorists out one of his
eyes.
Now,
why?
Because Seth is the embodiment of
destruction and malevolence,
and no matter how conscious you are,
if you encounter that even voluntarily,
the probability that it's going to
damage your consciousness is
extraordinarily high.
That's white people don't do it,
so the eyes torn out,
but seth is defeated and Horace banishes
him to the nether regions of the
kingdom.
You can't kill them.
Why?
Because the malevolent destructive
forest to threatened states never dies.
It's always there.
You can only remove it temporarily.
Now,
horace is King Pharaoh,
King God.
He's got his eyes and so you think,
well,
he's going to just pop that back in his
hand and then he's going to be able to
lead.
He's going to be able to take his place
at the upper most pantheon,
pantheon of gods properly,
but that isn't what he does.
He takes his eye and he goes back to the
underworld.
Just like Pinocchio,
going into the depths to rescue Japan
Eto and down there is the spirit of
Cyrus who's,
who's extend as a kind of half dad
ghost.
It gives us.
Oh,
Cyrus's,
I now will cyrus can see.
So what does that mean?
You go down into the chaotic,
when threatened by malevolence,
even to the point of damage to your
consciousness.
You go down into the chaos and you find
the dead spirit of your tradition and
you give it vision and so provided with
vision or Cyrus regenerates and then
Osiris and horus go back up to to to the
world linked together and rule jointly,
and the Egyptians believed that the
Pharaoh who had an immortal spirit was
the embodiment of the conjunction of
Horus and Osiris,
and that's what gave him sovereignty.
So you think about how brilliant that
is.
The Egyptians are trying to puzzle out
who should lead,
who should be pharaoh and what do you
have to be?
If you're going to be pharaoh in order
for things to work,
you have to be awake to malevolence and
chaos and you have to embody your
tradition and that puts you at the
highest pinnacle of the dominant
structure.
It's and that's the same as.
It's the same thing.
It's the same thing as the battle
between the gods across centuries or
Ian's and the emergence of the highest
possible moral virtue.
As a consequence of that competition,
it's the eye on the top of the pyramid,
right?
It's,
you know,
in the Washington monument there's a cap
on the Washington monument,
the protopic,
The Washington monument is a pyramid.
At the top of the pyramid is a cap.
It's made out of aluminum,
and the reason it's made out of aluminum
is because when they made the Washington
monument,
it was the most valuable metal known,
and so what does it mean?
It means there's a pyramid and there's
something at the top of it,
but the thing that's taught at the top
of the pyramid isn't the same as the
rest of the pyramid.
That's the thing.
The pyramid exists.
There's a dominance hierarchy.
Something climbs up to the top,
but it's not just at the top of one
pyramid.
It's at the top of all of them.
The thing that rises to the top of any
given pyramid is the same thing that can
dominate all pyramids.
It isn't good enough to be the best at a
dominance hierarchy.
What do you want to be is the best at
the set of all possible dominance
hierarchies.
Right?
And that's the thing that's gold at the
top of the pyramid,
and that's the eye.
That's what the Egyptians figured out.
And what does that mean?
It means the thing that puts you at the
top is attention.
Pay Attention,
keep your eyes open.
It's not the same as thinking.
It's not the same thing.
It's like watching.
And the thing about human beings is we
can see,
we can see better than any other
creature except birds of prey.
And so our capacity to see is in fact
what we'll use in the world.
Our brains are actually organized around
vision.
Unlike most animals,
their brains are organized around smell,
not us.
We can see we stand upright so we can
see a long distance and in our ability
to see is what saves us and what saves
our communities.
And that's what these stories are trying
to portray.
You might say,
well why didn't people just say so?
An answer to that is because they didn't
know
it took a long time to figure it out
forever.
It's taken forever to figure it out.
It's,
it's part of what I hoped when I wrote
this book and part of the reason that
I'm teaching it is because it seems to
me that it would be useful for everyone
to actually understand this instead of
just having it told as a story.
It's like,
that's great,
man.
Yes,
you need the story,
but why not also just understand it
so
well,
so that's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to understand this,
so
that's good enough for today.